>>> THIS IS ALVIN CHARLES, LAST
YEAR HE WAS CHARGED IN A
STABBING ATTACK AND HE WAS
FREED. HE'S BEHIND BARS ACCUSED
IN ANOTHER SUBWAY STABBING THAT
HAPPENED A WEEK AGO TONIGHT.
THIS TIME THE VICTIM, FATHER OF
THREE, TOMMY BAILEY, DIED. NEW
YORK CITY IS BECOMING
UNBEARABLE FOR THE GOOD PEOPLE
THAT LIVE HERE. THERE ARE THE
UNPROVOKED BEATINGS, BUT NEW
YORK GOVERNOR, KATHY HOCHUL
SAYS NOT TO WORRY.
>> THIS CITY IS STILL THE
SAFEST IN AMERICA.
LOOK AT CHICAGO AND SAN
FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES AND
ATLANTA AND WASHINGTON. PEOPLE
LEAVING NEW YORK, I AM NOT SURE
IF THEY'RE GOING TO GO BECAUSE
WE THE SAFEST AND BIGGEST CITY
IN AMERICA.
>> HEY KATHY, CUT THE BS,
ACTUALLY, KEEP IT GOING BECAUSE
VOTERS ARE SEEING WHO YOU TRULY
ARE.
MY NEXT GUEST IS TRAILING
HOCHUL BYLESS THAN TWO-POINTS
IN THE RACE FOR NEW YORK.
CONGRESSMAN ZELDIN, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING ME.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT THE PERSON
WHO GETS MURDERED ON THE L
TRAIN AND THAT'S WHY WE WERE
ALL MOURNING IN THE EMT WHO GOT
STABBED BEFORE HER LUNCH BREAK.
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED AT HOWARD
BEACH TRYING TO GET OFF A
SUBWAY, GETS ATTACKED BY A GUY
WHO HAD ONCE KILLED HIS OWN
GRANDMOTHER, OUT ON PAROLE,
VIOLATES PAROLE IN AUGUST. NOW
THE VICTIM IS BATTLING FOR HER
EYE SIGHT. I JUST CAME FROM
BUFFALO YESTERDAY WHERE THERE
WAS A WOMAN IN THAT AREA WHO ON
TUESDAY GOT ATTACKED BY HER OWN
HUSBAND, KEIR HUDSON, HAVING
THREE KIDS. HE GOT CHARGED WITH
ALL SORTS OF CRIMES ON TUESDAY.
HE GETS RELEASED. KEIR WAS
TELLING PEOPLE HE'S GOING TO
KILL ME. ON WEDNESDAY, SURE
ENOUGH HER HUSBAND KILLED HER
IN FRONT OF HER THREE KIDS. IF
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE BELL LAW, HE
WOULD HAVE STAYED DETAINED ON
TUESDAY. YOU COULD NOT BE
LOOKING AT ALL THESE CRIMES AND
SAYING EVERYTHING IS ALL FINE
HERE AND THERE IS NOTHING TO
SEE HERE.
>> CONGRESSMAN, I WAS SO HIT
HARD BY THE FATHER WHO WENT TO
MARRIOTT COURTYARD GOT SHOT BY
SOME GUY. HE'S OUT ON BAIL,
TOO. IT IS NEVER ENDING.
LISTEN, IT HAS BEEN 15 YEARS
SINCE YOUR STATE HAS WAITED FOR
A REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR. I NEVER
SEEN THE POLLS THIS TIGHT SINCE
I REMEMBER TRAVELING TO NEW
YORK FOR MY JOB. I DON'T KNOW,
IT HAS BEEN EIGHT OR NINE
YEARS. WHAT'S HAPPENING? IS
THIS POSSIBLE? COULD YOU WIN
THIS THING BASED ON HOW BAD
HOCHUL IS DOING?
>> WE ARE GOING TO WIN THIS.
>> YEAH.
>> NEW YORK LEADS THE ENTIRE
NATION OF POPULATION LOSS. I
DON'T THINK KATHY HOCHUL CAN
FINISH THE SENTENCE, NEW YORK
LEADS THE ENTIRE NATION OF
POPULATION LOSS BECAUSE --
>> NEW YORKERS ARE HITTING
THEIR BREAKING POINT, THEY FEEL
LIKE THEIR SAFETY ARE UNDER
ASTACK, THEIR WALLETS AND THEIR
KIDS' EDUCATION. THEY'RE
LOOKING AT OTHER STATES WHERE
THEY FEEL LIKE THEIR MONEY WILL
GO FURTHER. THAT'S WHY NEW YORK
LEADS THE ENTIRE NATION IN
POPULATION LOSS. EVEN IF YOU
ARE A LIFELONG DEMOCRAT, YOU
CAN'T RIDE THE SUBWAY BECAUSE
YOU ARE AFRAID OF BEING PUSHED
FROM AN ONCOMING SUBWAY CAR.
YOU SEE OTHER PEOPLE BEING
ATTACKED WHERE YOU USED TO BE
ABLE TO WALK 15 BLOCKS ON A
SUMMER NIGHT. NOW, YOU HAVE TO
CALL UBER JUST TO GO TWO
BLOCKS. PEOPLE'S SAFETY AND
ATTACKS ON THEIR WALLETS. NOW,
THEY WANT TO HIT EVERYBODY WITH
THE NEW CONGESTION PRICING FEE
WHERE YOU CAN GET CHARGED MORE
EVERYDAY. YOU WANT MORE PEOPLE
RIDE IN THE SUBWAY, MAKE THE
EXPERIENCE SAFE. MEANWHILE,
LISTEN, THERE IS A WHOLE LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE OTHER MEMBERS
IN THEIR FAMILY WHO ARE GONE
AND THEY REALIZE THIS IS IT. WE
HAVE TO SAVE OUR STATE. KATHY
HOCHUL IS IN OVER HER HEAD.
SHE'S REFERRING TO NEW YORKERS
AS -- SHE'S REFERRING TO
HERSELF AS THE MOTHER OF NEW
YORK, SHE RAISES TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON CORRUPT
SCANDAL. WE HAVE TO REMOVE HER
FROM OFFICE. I AM NOT IN THIS
RACE TO COME IN SECOND.
>> IT IS THE MOST EXCITING RACE
IN THE COUNTRY RIGHT N